[Music]
yeah so this is
from reddit relationship advice oh
and the question i think a lot of people
through corona [ __ ] are asking
themselves questions that maybe they
wouldn't normally ask
but so this is like i'm stuck with this
[ __ ] oh do how do i dump him
kinda oh well kind of but it's really
i've been asking like random questions
like
how did daenerys um like
murder the whole town why would she
randomly do that and by the way she was
like the biggest slave for her and then
all of a sudden she's like let's kill
everyone yeah yeah
those are the kind of questions that i
asked where were you at
i i didn't care at this point i mean the
real question is why is jon snow so
grossed out of his hot ass sister
yeah or his hot cousin it's just an ant
it's not even a
it's not in the system yeah of course i
don't know i just didn't
i tried not to remember that part
because that's part of white history
dude i'm like
we we we [ __ ] in our family all the time
i thought you meant ruining game of
thrones was part of white history well
that too
how's it going okay so i male 23 have
been dating my girlfriend 21 for three
years
from reddit relationship with but he
didn't want to say 420 we have lived in
all right
we have lived together for two years
have talked about getting married and
even our own pets together our
relationship has not been perfect
but we have always worked things out
good for you
about a year and a half ago into the
relationship
i'll let her go hang out with a guy
friend uh-oh steve's favorite
i know because it felt weird saying no
because it would look like i didn't
trust her
after that she told me that she had
that he had fingered her saying that she
didn't want it to happen
and she felt terrible she was waiting
she was raped
no she feels guilty after the fact she
didn't push it very hard apparently
because
i forgave her since
if he wrote this stuff he said that i
forgave her
since she told me about it and she seems
to be really upset i would have said
did it feel good nice bye
nice uh but not as good as you do it all
right cool we cooled in all right
but it has always made me paranoid about
it happening again because he's worried
if if he can finger her as good
no it's the trust because it's the
cheating part
no it's about the skill of fingering
it's trust
oh cause i would have been
self-conscious as like me too
is it my hands are my fingers too short
right stubby is it the size of the
fingers or the way that you move them
oh god don't do that geo no
or is it the motion of the ocean okay
that's the size of an average it's an
average dick
my question would be how did a finger
even get there
right how are you so close we were
[ __ ] hanging out we're having coffee
just reached over oh my god wow
yeah i was wearing a skirt i was asking
for it that might be one of those things
where she's doing a half-life
clearly she's like duh clearly but i'm
leaving out the part where i suck this
dick
and [ __ ] she was so guilty that she's
like he fingered me
but i didn't want it like come on man
she was telling the least bad part
yeah exactly he's like well i told him
the truth he fingered me but i didn't
tell him how
i deep throw the [ __ ] out of him and let
him cut let them come in my throat okay
so
for those of you who just judged
everything we just said and you're like
oh my god they're so enabling all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh no no check this out
uh it always made me paranoid about it
happening again fast forward to now
almost two years later i've noticed
she's been talking to a different guy
friend on snapchat
oh bro against my judgment
to give her privacy i looked at the chat
and i'm not sure how to feel
the conversation was about a dream she
had about him
in which they had sex he asked if she
liked it she said
maybe yeah she's so unsure
right she's not hey she didn't say yes
so he's like well she didn't say yes
in the conversation it seemed like this
wasn't the first time
either i feel betrayed but i don't know
what to do about it am i overreacting
or should i be worried no oh my
overreacting you're under-reacting as
[ __ ]
reacting worried just get the [ __ ] out
of there
thank you that's the definition of a
semp yes
yes that's a real sam finally he should
[ __ ] one of her friends and tell her and
be like i didn't really want to
yeah she rode my dick and i couldn't
stop her
i don't think her friends [ __ ] stamps i
don't understand cheaters in this
context because i'm like
why do they stay in relationships with
people for sure
they're really young too and maybe it's
just a comfort thing and maybe she just
doesn't know how to break it to him
damn two years later but like in this
case
and they live together right yeah well i
think i don't know
and they've even discussed having pets
you know what the real issue is he
doesn't know how to eat [ __ ] right
that's what i heard from you that's that
could be
i heard most guys don't yeah i heard you
can get a girl to come multiple times in
a row because you love eating [ __ ] so
much
start a course yeah it's it's in our
course
because people want to teach the art of
war i teach the art
the war of tongues it's the art of love
with tongues
the art of [ __ ] the war against the
orgasm that's why i teach against it
yeah
joe's going to tell you whose orgasm are
you against
excuse me no no it doesn't exist in
teams and steve orgasm
yeah we all know guys can come you can
see it you can look at it girls don't
come
yes no you're convinced that you came
but really you just had an overly
emotional moment in this sexual
situation with a man oh you didn't
actually come you don't know what that
is
oh true we aren't able to
and that's why i've never come right
except when they uh squirt
that's a real one that's not a [ __ ]
squirty is just peeing
is it did you eat it did you drink it
you'll be your mouth
can you move on with this conversation
yeah yeah yeah no i'm curious now
there is pee yeah yeah i just don't
think that girls can actually come i
think it's [ __ ] shut up
i think it's me i think it's media
propaganda ah the jig is up no
so then what do i what do i feel every
time you think creepy if i'm wrong no
eyes roll back i think that it makes
guys feel
insecure because they're always chasing
something that doesn't exist
oh so you're saying word so you're
calling me a liar yeah yeah well i think
you experienced something it just wasn't
what you thought it was
what is it then can you tell me a lot of
people claim they had ghost uh
encounters and like you know we know
that's [ __ ] so
is it there's a lot of shows that show
that little bro
yeah the pke meter yeah yeah yeah yeah
those are easy to fake
yes thank you no but in seriousness
what i find fascinating so what i find
fascinating about this is that the guy
will not stop trying to make excuses for
his child for this guy
so much he's super lost it's like
he's no confidence he's walking into his
girlfriend sucking the [ __ ] out of two
guys dicks and he's like he says sorry
sorry for barging in on you i don't know
it sorry i wanted
you connected your privacy i want to
hear your point of view on this before i
judge it yeah he's like
you know you guys were friends right
like what the [ __ ] and then he goes to
reddit am i doing friendship wrong
am i judging my male friends with [ __ ]
all over her face
and he goes oh honey you have something
there let me wipe it off
and she's like oh i guess i missed the
spot all over my face
she's like there's no way it's come yeah
she's like no it is
it definitely is is all your friends all
your friends oh my god
she's like oh you're dumb so wait what
is he going to read it for like oh if
he's being too rough
he wants to know it's like he came on my
face i didn't want it though
nice i know how he's [ __ ] i wanted
him to come on my tits
because in the face you if it
accidentally gets in your eye your eye
gets red that's true it can happen oh he
came on my face
i felt i felt bad about that i always
have i feel bad for this guy though
because it sounds like he loves her so
much that he's in disbelief and he
doesn't want to even
believe that it's happening he got with
her at a young age so he probably is
like his first real love
yeah you can't let go yeah you can't let
go you don't know when things
like how bad are things supposed to feel
before i break up
that's pretty bad man i think you should
like 19 or 20.
and he's like 23 now yeah because it was
two years
until the first incident when he's
talking about marriage too right right
and the pets
but marriage no well the pets was the
rest of your life so what would you say
to this cat break up with her yeah dude
you got to leave
her man yeah get the [ __ ] out of there
show her your reddit post what's the
cheater what was jeter man
how do you how do you like teach him
not to let people walk all over him like
that
yeah because he's always blaming himself
if things are hurting you
then that's where you set a clear
boundary yeah yeah yeah
he's so worried about being like
possessive and jealous and all that
stuff exactly i think that's
another reason too is he's not sure if
he's acting accordingly or he's paranoid
he's overcompensating on the wrong side
though yeah he's not giving any credit
to the other side he needs homies
exactly he's a good circle to like help
him out
he doesn't sound like he has like his
whole life is like revolving around it
sounds like she doesn't let allow him to
have friends
no well he doesn't also do because
he let her hang out with a guy what the
[ __ ] is that
i mean there's got to be something
that's just weird in the relationship
well he's too afraid to say anything
he's making things sound like
it's perfect and great isn't it weird
when guys like
if if you're a guy especially for a
married man or like you have a
girlfriend of a long time or fiance
and you just go hang out with some girl
it's just weird to me
one on one yeah no i have female friends
well but then you hang out one on one
but previous to they were friends before
you met
your your lady now yeah yeah so they're
not friends after
right so i mean that's the weird if i
meet like a a female person and they're
my friend i don't
yeah because it comes down to the person
because it's like if you're going to
cheat you're going to cheat no matter
what whether they're your friend
of course but well i draw a line for me
here's the thing
they're unfuck wittable in our first
year of being together
i didn't know about steve's feelings on
that yet and i hung out with guys
one-on-one and
even guys that i had hooked up with in
the past but i didn't
i didn't have any feelings for them and
i didn't have any attraction to them
it was just purely a like hey i have
this work thing and like do you
do you think like we could grab coffee
and talk about it and i was like okay
so i saw it more as a business thing
that doesn't sound like hanging out
that's not right but it's coffee so or
lunch or whatever
and so like and i still was friends with
them before
because i feel like if there's an agenda
then you're not hanging out true
yeah and like hopefully the agenda is
not hooking up yeah yeah
yeah yeah maybe maybe i'm more simp than
you are that's true
do you know what i mean okay it could be
because maybe you're not a sim as much
so you're like nah because you know what
happens
i think i'm a stamp don't don't say it
but what if they're ugly as [ __ ]
like you ever think that they're so ugly
you're like nikki will never [ __ ]
but sometimes it's not about have you
seen my ex boyfriends no
no my thing is like if i was worried
about it then i wouldn't be
dating that person to begin with because
that means i don't trust them
you know well of course but trust is a
whole whole different yeah but then it
makes him uncomfortable and i'm like oh
that makes sense like and then i don't
really care to see them
but it's not like i cut you off from
friends that were deep or anything
yeah yeah it was a guy any friendship if
it was like that it would be different
like
he had a friend um a girl that was his
friend and they would talk on the phone
sometimes when we were first dating
but then he was like i don't really need
this relationship well it put me in a
weird
position because uh in when i was like
in the back in the day nothing ever
happened between us but back in the day
i had feelings for this chick
back in the way day and then knowing
that i had that
it felt like an unrequited love aka an
unfair situation to compare with
somebody who's really my
my chick and so even if we had a problem
and i'd take it to this girl who had
unrequited love with we never actually
had a relationship nothing was tested
i'm supposed to go to her and be like yo
yeah nikki and me blah blah blah blah
blah
this girl is a blemish free record she
can just stand there
and like stand on the mountain with a
white robe on and be like i
am perfect i've never [ __ ] with you
and so it's not a fair
comparison and so putting nicki in a
situation where it's her versus the
unrequited chick
who i never got with from high school is
not fair
so i just cut that out of my mind that's
a lot of people do they romanticize that
[ __ ] that they're going to
and yeah but they put themselves in that
situation right so i took myself out of
that situation
to be loyal to you yeah i did insane
stop seeing i stopped like
hanging out with any guys that would i
would possibly think would make you
uncomfortable so i think that's the
the the part where you guys have that
inkling of maybe they might be an
interest so you prevent yourself but if
there's someone that's
completely disgusting you will never
[ __ ] touch them but they might purely
business but they might like me
or they might like right if you know
that they don't it's not about them
it's not about me being interested in
them it's about me creating an image of
me
hanging with somebody it looks better
but if this was purely platonic i think
that can happen
that's why i i don't believe what you
guys believe what do you think about
this because they brought this up to me
when you were here on a jk episode
like what if me and joe hung out one day
and had coffee absolutely not
only if his dick was perfectly cut off
or like you know like if it was that's
so different it's crazy
joe is basically my best pal it's like
there's no way i feel like if it's a
group like we all hang out in a group
and like it's
like it's a different thing i get what
you're saying though if it's
new people new people like and people
that are outside the circle
that's weird because i don't know that
girl that he's friends with and he
didn't know the guys that i was friends
with right but since we all know each
other that's different so at this range
it's like family
yeah it's different so it's like hey
nikki let's go
and [ __ ] build a new program yeah
okay right that's
that's completely different there's no
even hesitation there
because we all know each other it's so
different i'll be like well he fingered
me but i didn't want it it was for like
yeah does that make you it made me vomit
while i was like why are you vomiting
about fingering my wife that's incest
bro
yeah it felt weird even say ugh i would
think you're not
you